hey there eric voss in the new rockstars
blue dungeon here and
we got a mandalorian season 2 trailer
yus
content and because i live on the west
coast and like to sleep in a little bit
i truly got to wake up to this little
surprise so of course i'm going to spend
all day today breaking down
this thing frame by frame you know the
way new rockstars normally does
but for right now you are going to get
to see a true raw
first-time reaction to this and that's
not to say the reactions i did the
batman trailer in the dune trailer
weren't
it's just i'm uh still waking up and uh
i'm feeling a little rough
here we go
ooh
the razor crest looks damaged why is the
hangar bay
open uh oh
it's not good
was that didgeridoo deemed such
destruction
you must reunite it with its own
kindness
where this you must determine
the songs of eon's past tell of battles
between mandalore the great
and an order of sorcerers called jedi
is that to search the galaxy and deliver
this creature
to a race of enemy sorcerers
[Music]
i'm gone this is the way
this is the way all right
look at that
yellow squadron i don't want to take a
sip
you know this is no place for a child
[Laughter]
nope nope
this is the way this is the way
hmm hear that flute wow okay i uh
i'm loving it that that's great i i was
totally gonna do the thing where i take
a sip and and spit it out but i'm not
i'm not gonna fake it for you guys
also i have lots of electrical equipment
here that would not be safe
all right i gotta put down the mug to
talk about this this was uh looking
real good one thing we loved about
mandalore in season one is how grounded
of a street view this was of the star
wars universe
and you know that the people who worked
on the prequels like dave filoni
totally wanted to explore that more
which they got to do a bit in clone wars
and
in rebels but now they get to do it in
live action build these beautiful worlds
with this
interesting vfx setup that they use for
the mandalorian
we're seeing lamplit streets we're
seeing like oceans and ports
which is something we only got a little
bit of in the prequels i know there was
that uh amphibious invasion in kashyyyk
and revenge of the sith
on the street levels of coruscant it
felt kind of moody nighttime like that
sometimes but all this looks practical
and
tactile which is a bit ironic because
using the screen the way they do
a lot of it is vfx really it looks like
it's picking up where the first season
left off
we're following mando denjarin taking
the child baby yoda and trying to track
down the jedi
to return him to these evil sorcerers
not evil i know there's just not a lot
of them and hopefully we do get to see
the more clouded view of the jedi's
morality that the clone wars did a
really good job exploring
now again i'm going to go through this
more frame by frame in the details but
already i just want to point out a
couple things to you that stood out to
me as i was reacting to it okay so first
we got to talk about this mystery hooded
woman
um at first i was like oh is this our
rosario dawson
but i don't think that's ahsoka that
hood would be way more bulkier going
over ahsoka's head i'm thinking this
could be sabine wren
she's the mandalorian revolutionary who
would be with ahsoka so asuka
may be behind the other crate there
we're also seeing some of this port city
this water planet you do see some mon
calamari in the background there
so is this moncala i don't know might be
too soon to tell there's probably a lot
of ocean-covered planets in the star
wars universe but the most interesting
location i'm seeing is this snow-covered
planet
and this looks super familiar to me but
for a couple reasons first there's a
shot of baby yoda in this like puffy
snow
that reminded me a lot of that
snow-covered planet in the final shot of
the clone wars animated series you know
this is a planet where ahsoka tano
buried all the clone troopers that were
part of her group
there was that great final moment where
vader found this planet found these
helmets looked up saw the bird
remembered ahsoka he's clearly tracking
her down and maybe the mandalorian is
following in the footsteps of that
investigation that search
but the real reason it looks super
familiar to me is this trench
this ice cave that mando appears to be
going into that looks
a lot like ilum that's the ice planet
from jedi fallen order where the crystal
cave was this is where the jedi might be
hiding
illumi is the same planet that was later
turned into starkiller base if you have
questions about the timeline here yes
the first order would have been
terraforming this base already
but the trench i'm pretty sure was
already there and this also could be
showing us the origin of the first
order's operations so this one shot
right here might be tying in of course
the mandalorian with
jedi followed order with the sequel
trilogy in the first order
and the jedi it's a very interesting
location i am hoping this is illum
and we see this fighting ring with some
uh gamoreans going at it
i am loving all those flags there kind
of reminds me of a maz kanata's hideout
in the horse awakens so she had all
those pod racer flags hanging out
outside in the courtyard but i'm
assuming these banners are
for different past champions of this
ring and of course i do love the way
baby yoda just kind of nopes out of that
fight poor little guy sees so much
conflict
i mean look let's be honest it's not
like this little thing's afraid to uh
see conflict and destroy [ __ ] and yes
he's not a baby he's like over 50 years
old so clearly you could just imagine
this as like an old man in a nearby
saloon closed in the shutters
no i don't want no trouble here but also
because it's powerful he knows that he
could just choke someone if he gets too
close to much asperilla look i'm just
gonna say everything that i loved about
mandalorian season one season two seems
to be doing
grounded realism of the world the
relationship between mando and the
child all the tech being broken and
dirty
this is the star wars that i believe
george lucas really conceived of with
the very first 1977 star wars and that's
one that dave filoni and john favres
seem to be exploring and pulling on the
thread of
in fact i love how in the interview last
week john favreau was like hey i keep
pitching ideas to dave filoni and dave
bloney's like
you can't do that in star wars like you
want to use the term a dime a dozen and
day palone's like we don't have
dimes in this universe but i think that
kind of conversation is what makes the
mandalorian great kind of an ebb and
flow between the world building
and the grounding and realism but yeah
i'm gonna stop talking now so i can go
through this frame by frame to find all
the details that i missed just now and
that you might have missed that video is
gonna be coming out
tomorrow so be sure to subscribe hit
that notification bell so you get that
video right when it comes out follow me
on instagram
eavos follow new rockstars thanks for
watching and um just so i can say that i
did it here we go
[Music]
you
[Music]